president Trump's first State of the
Union address his son Donald Trump Union
what you were in the gallery I was I got
to be you're not feeling well you think
you've had this bad flu that everybody
had you feeling better keep working
matter you're a trump beekeeper good
night I watched and and look I'm a
conservative and I talked to a lot of
friends during the speech tonight this
is the speech that conservatives have
wanted to hear since Reagan more people
independently telling me that then any
other comment I got tonight cuz I think
it was phenomenal I mean and you could
see it not just from the Republicans I
mean I got a leg workout just standing
up every five seconds because he hit
every point but watching the Democrats
was actually where I noticed it because
you could see them all wanting to stand
Sean you could see them all almost
looking around like we almost have to
stand for this but the derangement is
real no they have to do the opposite
they've been forced to take the opposite
approach of everything that he does
everything that he says so even things
that are just common sense solutions for
the American people they have to do the
opposite and you could see it was
amazing to watch if you have record low
unemployment and if you break it down
demographically record low unemployment
for black America for Hispanic America
for women a 17-year low you have
economic growth and success how do you
sit down and not want to cheer that
considering this meant a lot of
suffering the last eight years I don't
know it doesn't make any sense to me and
uh you know again I think those are
things that people see when they see
thousands of dollars going back into
their wallets when they see billions
being repatriated to this country that
money being infused into the economy and
I wasn't all that long ago when Nancy
Pelosi was touting a $40 tax rebate
right but thousands of dollars in
bonuses thousands of dollars being paid
little runners crumbs are crumbs yeah
it's amazing I didn't realize inflation
was that bad in four years things
changed so you know seeing that this was
a unifying speech it was a speech to all
Americans he hit everyone deeply and it
was amazing to watch it was amazing to
see it firsthand you know when you think
of 2.4 million jobs 200,000 in the
manufacturing sector alone you think 2
million Americans off of food stamps
that was one of the big issues I
remember one of the first interviews I
did with you you called your dad
blue-collar Republican I called him a
blue-collar billionaire I'm sorry call a
billionaire you probably and it's true I
used to get criticized for it you'd see
it I mean it gets those people and you
know why he gets those people Sean
because like you that's where he spent
his time building his business he didn't
become a great builder in an office he
became a great builder by being on job
sites being around the men and women who
built those projects talking with them
not at them and I know you've done the
same thing in the course of your life
working in restaurants being a
dishwasher cook a bartender busboy
waiter and then building houses framing
roofing tile painting it changed my life
and and and honestly those are the
Americans that have suffered correct
David they are the Forgotten Americans
right and he's giving them hope he's
always been able to speak to them I mean
hey I get it
he's an unlikely person to be able to
breach those boundaries right the blue
is a billionaire from New York City
being the guy the voice of the
blue-collar American but he can do it
and he does it genuinely and now mm-hmm
they took a chance they voted for him
and now they're seeing the results and
it's amazing to watch people try to ask
me about your dad because I've always
been and remained today a Reagan
conservative yes and I keep arguing with
people I'm not a nationalist I'm not a
populist I in a conservative and it's
still a Reagan conservative I look
through the list of accomplishments
we'll put it back up on the screen a
list of principles then from judges to
immigration to energy independence all
these are all important issues and
that's what has what has happened in a
year the Heritage Foundation actually
said it I know it was more conservative
than Reagan I saw that and more
successful by the numbers that Reagan
which by the way for them you know they
weren't exactly always the biggest fan
right so for them to come around and say
wait a minute this is working you see
the Republicans doing hey last week you
saw it it's the first time the
Republicans didn't just fold I mean the
Republicans have a history of being
amazing at snatching defeat from the
jaws of victory that's their specialty
that's their superpower now they have
someone who will fight for them someone
who will back them up and go to the wall
I mean you know that's what's been
incredible and so
now that they see that I think their
spirit is invigorated and by the way
more importantly the voters who voted
for them who entrusted my father with
this incredible responsibility they see
it too let's talk about the distractions
you've fathered and all the
accomplishments had to be achieved in an
environment of correct I would argue
historically unprecedented hatred
vitriol conspiracy theories lies you
yourself have known you know by the way
I love it I thought I was tough on
Twitter at one point I can't compare to
you or your dad well listen a yeah when
you've gone through what we've gone
through the amazing thing is though the
media the left they went so all in on
this conspiracy theory because they
couldn't figure it out how could this
guy do this to you are anointed one are
chosen one you know with one-tenth the
money one-tenth the staff they did it
because they were actually speaking to
real Americans so they couldn't so they
needed these things to be true they went
all in with their credibility for this
nonsense to be true now what's amazing
that means without evidence without
anything but what's been so amazing for
me despite in 25 hours of congressional
testimony millions in legal fees
hey the only thing that they found out
was that they themselves were the ones
doing all of these things and I really
hope for all of that stuff to come out
because imagine what he could do given
what he's accomplished in the last year
imagine what he can do without this
fictitious baggage imagine what he could
do if he was just unleashed to actually
fight without all of those distractions
you know I say this often and I spent a
lot of time it was about a year ago when
we first reported on this program with
John Solomon and Sarah Carter that in
fact trump tower had been yet there was
a warrant a FISA woman they had been
spying going on now we learn a lot of
the background imagine if your dad fixed
the primary had it rigged against 16
other people imagine if James Comey and
other FBI agents rigged an investigation
exonerated your father before actually
investigating him imagine if your dad
did paper Russian propaganda through a
dossier and imagine that dossier was
used as a foundation for a warrant
against Hillary let's reverse rolls here
would it's you can't even I mean if this
stuff if you heard about this stuff
going on in Angola or you'd say wow
that's terrible yeah but it's happening
on you know
backyard arey you know this isn't a
banana republic I mean this is the
United States of America and for this to
be going on at that level you know and
again I think we have to make the
distinction because you heard it tonight
you know my father is fighting for the
guys in law enforcement and all of those
agencies but the boots not the suits
that are the lawyers at the top you know
they're not the same yeah I was at the
floor of the shot show last week right
and I had 15 no less than 15 FBI agents
both active and retired coming tell your
father to keep going because those guys
on the seventh floor
they're tarnishing my badge the blood
sweat and tears that I put into four
decades Wow yeah so same remarks they
get and think he's still fighting for
law enforcement for the military all the
things that he promised but there's a
difference between those boots and those
suits at the top those suits what we're
seeing the corruption is real and when
you look at it what other conclusion can
we draw that this is the prior
administration effectively weaponizing
the DOJ and the FBI you know what one of
the things that he said tonight that
really stood out to me is for example
people have different diseases maybe
they've been given a death sentence yes
and we have government bureaucracy that
prevents people from making choices
maybe maybe they want the right to
experiment with a drug that we're told
is promised do you have to lose nothing
but the government those people behind
me over there and the freezing-cold yes
they don't care no they want any chance
at life and we're giving it to live its
own if it would encourage medical
development right it's not always gonna
work okay it's not but when it does
think of how fast we can expedite those
things getting other people those same
medications but he use the example is it
for me I relate to a best as a builder
right the road example yeah we built the
Empire State Building in a year now it
takes ten years to get a permit to build
a little County Road and the ten years
to get a permit now son or it's sure let
alone actually building it those are the
things those are the regulations that
he's cutting the nonsense the layers and
layers and layers of government
bureaucracy we don't need them now this
country got to where it is without all
that what an amazing statistic and I
always pride myself on giving out a lot
of statistics I don't know if you've
heard of fuel no what's or twice but
when he said that they eliminated more
burdensome regulation than every
their president combined in one year in
the you know one year he's done more
than entire administration but isn't
that what really the government has
gotten so big so bureaucratic between
that and him taking on the culture and
talking about the flag and talking about
the anthem and challenging the NFL and I
was but but I think what he's done I
think one of the reasons he's such
fierce opposition he's bringing in that
business acumen he's trying to wipe away
all the clutter so that we can build up
the country but they love that culture
well that culture has made them rich
it's made their friends very rich they
go on to become lobbyists that's why the
Beltway is the richest place in America
on the backs of the American worker
and yet we haven't this area hasn't
created anything they don't build
anything they don't manufacture anything
they don't create anything they peddle
influence it's what's happened and so
he's giving that back to the people he's
allowing them to create these allowing
them to use their money the other side I
mean you see why I don't want to go to
war to have your own money why didn't
you go with your father I remember
asking you that at the time you know I
don't know I can do more on the side you
know I I'm still always gonna be very
vocal all the kids I think you have the
same temperament as him maybe that's why
we don't want that personality may not
always work but you know I'm just as an
American and as a father of five young
kids I'm so proud to be able to watch
what he's doing is I want to make sure
that they grow up in America that I grew
up in I was vacant experiences those
same freedoms when you look at the
attacks on so much I mean today when I'm
looking at some of the Democrats again
yeah they don't stand up for God today
reluctant to stand up for the flag they
don't even think about standing up for
the anthem I'm watching it in the same I
can't even believe you're gonna say he's
saying all of them didn't okay but you
know the vast majority you could see it
reluctantly huh god I got to do it
because otherwise I may get some heat
and he's taking that culture on and he's
hit him hard but that's the swamp it is
that's the sewer and that's why you need
someone from the outside I'm sorry
you're sick glad you could make it
anyway and good to see we appreciate you
being with us it to be with you